her answers does continue in a plea to
the public from metro police today
graciela gomez was shot and killed last
halloween and the person who pulled the
trigger remains on the loose christian
casares joining us live in studio with
more on who police are hoping to connect
with well brian graciela gomez was shot
and killed back in october while she was
at a halloween house party police have
reached a dead end in the case and are
now asking all those party goers for
help
it's a tragedy
there has to be information out there
somewhere a las vegas family torn apart
by the shooting death of graciela gomez
is asking the community to speak up
after investigators hit a wall on leeds
everyone in this community knows each
other someone can run into each other
and there's connections everywhere so
someone actually sees something and
we're just asking for a helping hand the
22 year old woman attended a party
halloween night inside this rented home
near stewart and nellis police say once
word of the party got out on social
media things quickly got out of control
the host started patting down guests at
the door as a safety precaution a group
of hispanic males arrived and they
refused to be patted down
at the party
that started a confrontation between
the host
and the people who were trying to get in
moments later detectives say a four-door
sedan pulled up and someone opened fire
hitting gomez and two others gomez did
not survive we know there were
additional party goers at the front
entrance when the party was taking place
and we also know that there were people
who fled the party prior to the police
arrival that were asking for them to
reach out to metro homicide gomez served
with the nevada army national guard
since 2018 she was a graduate of las
vegas high and provided aid to the covet
19 task force in las vegas her mother
asking whoever pulled the trigger to do
the right thing and turn themselves in
being
piano
well crime stoppers is offering a two
thousand dollar reward for information
in this case that number
702-385-5555 and police say they want
any type of information from the
community remember you can't stay
anonymous christian casa is live local
now